breaking news right now out of thailand  rescue teams are working through the  night to save 12 boys and their coach  trapped inside a cave  the monsoon had come early the  conditions in the cave were impossible  there was a very strong feeling that the  children couldn't be still alive we need  expert cave divers out here  this has actually got our name all over  it  you couldn't see your hand in front of  your face  trying to wriggle through holes that i  couldn't rip through again and again  how many of you  we didn't think was possible to dive the  children out i was like well what does  the impossible look like  my mind was on overdrive oh my god am i  going to be good enough  if they die it's going to tear me apart  if you don't dive everyone will die once  you start it cannot stop  believe  believe